[Music]
you can easily judge the character of a
man by how he treats those who can do
nothing for him
[Music]
thinking is easy acting is difficult and
to put one's thoughts into action is the
most difficult thing in the world
enjoy when you can and endure when you
must
[Music]
why not every day at least to hear a
little song read a good poem see a fine
picture and if it were possible to speak
a few reasonable words
correction does much but encouragement
does more
a person hears only what they understand
[Music]
doubt can only be removed by action
to think is easy to act as hard but the
hardest thing in the world is to act in
accordance with your thinking
courage is the commitment to begin
without any guarantee of success
[Music]
kindness is the golden chain by which
society is bound together
as soon as you trust yourself you will
know how to live
if you treat an individual as he is he
will remain how he is
but if you treat him as if he were what
he ought to be and could be he will
become what he ought to be and could be
[Music]
a man sees in the world what he carries
in his heart
[Music]
magic is believing in yourself if you
can do that you can make anything happen
there is nothing more frightful than
ignorance in action
what has not started today is never
finished tomorrow
nothing is more highly to be prized than
the value of each day
knowing is not enough we must apply
willing is not enough we must do
i love those who yearn for the
impossible
[Music]
which is the best government that which
teaches us to govern ourselves
[Music]